líderes mundiales flotando en el agua y
aparentemente ajenos a la situación esta
alegoría fue montada por activistas en
glasgow como una forma de denunciar la
falta de acciones y compromisos
concretos en la cob 26 para limitar el
aumento de la temperatura global en 1,5
grados centígrados una meta lejos de
cumplirse según el grupo climate action
tracker los compromisos asumidos en la
cumbre aún llevarían el calentamiento a
2.4 grados a finales de siglo
esta es una representación de las
negociaciones los líderes hablan hacen
promesas y alrededor de ellos el mundo
se hunde no necesitamos promesas
necesitamos políticas y eso es lo que
falta los científicos han advertido
largamente que una subida superior a los
1,5 grados representaría un punto de no
retorno pero alcanzar ese objetivo luce
improbable según el grupo de
investigación en el mejor escenario
posible la temperatura podría limitarse
a 18 grados este siglo y para eso la
mayoría de las naciones debería
implementar políticas a corto plazo que
ni siquiera han comenzado a aplicar
los cruces la verdad es que estamos
lejos de la marca y no solo un poco
antes de que finalice esta conferencia
debemos asegurarnos de tomar decisiones
que nos encaminen hacia la consecución
de nuestro objetivo y esto debe hacerse
dentro de este año porque se nos está
acabando el tiempo es running out para
alcanzar el umbral establecido las
emisiones globales de gases de efecto
invernadero deben disminuir en un 45%
para 2030 y se debe alcanzar la
neutralidad para 2050 aunque incluso
cumpliendo con esas metas podría no ser
suficiente